[Música]
revista de prensa de hoy lunes 20 de
junio ya está conmigo en el estudio rosa
pérez más de urosa vamos a dedicar esta
revista de prensa a comentar como
titulan en los medios de comunicación
internacionales y nacionales también la
victoria de petró en colombia empezamos
por los medios nacionales rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente no sobre todo pues
a nivel de colombia es evidente pero
también a nivel regional pues hay muchos
medios de comunicación que destacan no
la victoria de petró como el espectador
de colombia este medio de aquí de bogotá
que dice cambio histórico y pues coloca
en portada esta imagen ayer en la sede
de digamos donde y petro y francia todo
el equipo del pacto histórico recibió
los resultados y recibió pues esta
victoria no hay cambio también pues
porque básicamente es la primera vez
como ya hemos repetido que la izquierda
llega a la presidencia en colombia no en
200 años dice
el espectador dice primera vez que la
izquierda llega a la presidencia en
colombia con 11 2 millones de votos
gustavo petro ganó la presidencia por
primera vez para la izquierda en
colombia insistimos su gobierno dijo no
será de odios ni venganzas
el uribismo anuncia que a la oposición y
la gente espera un cambio real pasamos a
el país de cali que tampoco es un medio
especialmente de izquierdas pero en cali
tory que digamos petro ganó con
muchísima ventaja respecto a su
contrincante rodolf hernández y dice
también en el país de cali pues repite
las cifras estos 11 millones señalando
que he sido el presidente más votado de
la historia del país y que también he
sido las elecciones con mayor
participación con un 58% de afluencia a
las urnas vamos con el tiempo que es
este medio pues a nivel nacional de
colombia que dice construcción de
consensos el reto del presidente electo
gustavo petro y cita parte de su
discurso en que invitó a la oposición a
dialogar construir un pacto nacional y
describe a petro como el hombre que no
se dejó devorar por la viola dice fue
guerrillero congresista diplomático
alcalde de bogotá y ahora jefe de estado
electo y para terminar ya con esta ronda
dice el colombiano de medellín pues de
esta región más conservadora de
antioquia dice
pues señala entre otras cosas 'francia
márquez porque recordemos que también es
histórica la figura de francia marc es
no pues lideresa social
afrodescendiente y mujer por primera vez
en la presidencia de colombia y
finalmente es ella quien encarna sobre
todo pues la representación de un sector
de muchos sectores de la población que
nunca han ha tocado el poder no dice la
silla vacía por ejemplo en relación a
francia marc es una líder social de la
toma a suárez una mujer negra quien
antes de ser abogada fue empleada
doméstica ella represente a sectores
étnicos y regionales que nunca habían
ocupado la casa de nariño y bueno hoy
comienza una nueva etapa para colombia
dice y esa foto dice más que mil
palabras en relación al escenario donde
pues se subieron los líderes del pacto
histórico y de sus familias ayer para
recibir esta victoria y ya para terminar
el país
escribe inés santaeulalia petro doblegó
con mayoría absoluta las resistencias
que genera en parte de los ciudadanos el
mero hecho de mentar su nombre el anti
petr ismo es enorme en un país marcado
por la violencia de décadas de conflicto
y dice pedro es petro ex guerrillero y
de izquierda encarna para muchos
colombianos lo que siempre han querido
mantener alejado del poder estos eran
mayoría hasta este domingo bueno rosa
como entonces se dicen los medios de
comunicación por fuera de colombia como
reseña en esta victoria de gustavo
vamos a petro vamos a revisar
entonces el continente americano exacto
empezamos por méxico con el medio la
jornada que dice se impuso el
exguerrillero en la segunda vuelta pero
digamos en el titular grande dice
colombia elige a petro su primer
presidente progresista y vemos esta
imagen con la foto no de dylan cruza un
momento que fue pues muy emotivo ayer
pues en la celebración del pacto
histórico porque este chico recordemos
reuniones muy en transacciones sí exacto
no y representa un poco pues la
violencia de la fuerza pública
en colombia y su madre recordemos subió
al escenario a dar la bienvenida a
gustavo petro como presidente electo del
país por otro lado la tercera de chile
dice el triunfo de petró confirma el
giro a la izquierda en la región
recordemos que este sábado se cumplieron
100 días de mandato de gabriel boric en
chile por otro lado correo del sur de
bolivia dice petro pide a gobiernos
progresistas abandonar el extractivismo
y virar a economías productivas
recordemos que ayer petro hablaba de
colombia potencia mundial de la vida
este medio de bolivia señala que ésta es
tacita estas palabras eran sobre todo en
referencia a pues bolivia y venezuela en
relación a su dependencia de las
exportaciones puede ser de hidrocarburos
entre otras cosas y ya pues para
terminar con este recorrido un poco del
continente vemos el 'new york times' que
dedica también su foto más destacada en
la portada en colombia elige un líder de
izquierdas rosa vamos ahora con las
legislativas a francesas como abordó la
prensa también como abordó la prensa
francesa estas elecciones legislativas
bueno pues un poco lo que se repite
también es pues la
el golpe a la plataforma presidencial de
manuel macro por ejemplo para resumirlo
liberación dice la bofetada un poco y
con la imagen ahí pues del presidente
francés y básicamente para recordar un
poco los puntos que destacan la mayoría
de medios es que la extrema derecha pues
de agrupación nacional del partido de
marín le pen pasó de tener ocho
diputados en 2017 a 90 en estas
elecciones imaginen es pues multiplicar
por 11 pues su representación en la
asamblea nacional por otro lado también
la unión de izquierda es la no consigue
colocarse como segunda fuerza de sus y
pues con los escaños digamos con el
escenario menos optimista que digamos se
apuntaba en las encuestas bueno así las
cosas de en francia- rosa vamos a
primero hablar obviamente con nuestro
primer invitado del día de colombia el
segundo invitado el día va a ser para
avisar estas elecciones francesas rosas
gracias por la información nos vemos
mañana cómo hacer revista de prensa
[Música]